so Paul ruse samagina the man whose
story was featured in the Hollywood film
Hotel Rwanda is due to be released from
prison in 2021 he was sentenced to 25
years on terrorism charges tied to an
organization opposed to Rwandan
president Paul kagame ruse sabagina
worked as the manager of a hotel in
Kigali during the 1994 genocide and
saved the lives of more than 1200 people
Malcolm Webb is joining us from Goma
Malcolm what are you learning
we've heard from the random government
that will pull us as a beginner is to be
released either later today or possibly
on Sunday in spite of one and a half
years ago having been sentenced to 25
years for terrorism as you said now we
know that the US has been putting
pressure on the Rwandan government for
his release since the beginner has a
permanent right to to live in the United
States
president Paul kagame of Rwanda is
mentioned this once or twice over the
last month saying that this situation at
some point might be resolved now Rwandan
government sources have said that
recesser beginner has written a letter
to President kagame pleading clemency we
don't know if that's true or not but it
would certainly be at odds with
everything that was Esther beginner and
his associates have said since he was
detained in August 2020 in what was
widely described as a kidnapping or
abduction he was in Dubai at the time
and was deceived and boarded a plane
that was paid for by rwanda's government
and flown to Kigali against his will his
detention and trial follow that and
throughout the trial he refused to
participate he said it wasn't fair as
did International legal Watchdogs and
rights groups
Malcolm put a little bit more context
and you've begun to do so context around
this for us because Paul Russia sabagina
is considered a hero by many
internationally and then convicted on
terrorism charges domestically
foreign
become a Critic of rwanda's President
Paul kagame and there was some videos on
YouTube that indicated that he was
affiliated with the political opposition
group that was also connected to an
armed group here in Democratic Republic
of Congo that wanted to overthrow
rwanda's government this was evidence
that Rwanda said indicated that he was
guilty of the crimes with which he was
eventually tried but legal rights groups
say that evidence was never presented in
meaningfully in court in that trial that
they said was unfair now political
opposition and rights groups in Miranda
have for decades documented uh
disappearances assassinations and
detentions of of government critics so
in that sense there was nothing new
about these uh complaints but what was
different in this case is that Hollywood
had already told the story and they said
recessive vagina was a hero and so when
he was produced in Kigali in a pink
jumpsuit wearing handcuffs that caused
outcry particularly in the U.S which
resulted in we understand substantial
diplomatic pressure from America on
Rwanda over the subsequent uh couple of
years
my Malcolm Webb reporting on this forest
from the Democratic Republic of Congo
thank you